hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown most of the
top-tier Democratic presidential
candidates will be campaigning in Iowa
this weekend ahead of Monday's caucuses
the billionaire contender Michael
Bloomberg will not be host Jessica
Rosenthal sits down with his 2020
campaign senior advisor Tim O'Brien to
discuss why the former New York City
Mayor is banking on Super Tuesday
instead O'Brien also opens up about
Bloomberg's upcoming campaign ad set to
air during the Super Bowl host Lisa
Brady chats with veteran fox news
journalist Geraldo Rivera who discusses
his remarkable career and new Fox Nation
documentary series I am Geraldo 50 years
plus commentary from head writer of
Kennedy on the Fox Business Network
Jimmy fela the Fox News rundown is a
Daily News podcast where we take a
deeper look at the stories important to
you you can subscribe on your favorite
podcast player by going to FoxNews
podcast.com i'm shannon bream I'm Tom
shaloo I'm Maria Bartiromo and this is
the Fox News rundown
Friday January 31st 2020
I'm Jessica Rosenthal he's not in Iowa
and he won't be as he spends millions on
advertising Mike Bloomberg had
threatened to run for president before
but this time it's different in more
ways than one it looks a lot of polling
data and what he saw was that the
current field wouldn't beat Donald Trump
in in general election
I'm Lisa Brady a lot can happen in 50
years especially if you're Geraldo
Rivera he's looking back on decades in
the news business by going back to the
beginning I used this medium for
positive social change I did something
and I'm Jimmy Fowler I've got the final
word on the Fox News rundown
[Music]
the Democratic candidates are in Iowa or
headed there ahead of Monday's caucuses
with one notable exception former New
York City Mayor Mike Bloomberg Saturday
he'll be in Denver yesterday he was in
Washington DC talking about homelessness
and housing Bloomberg isn't competing in
the first four states to hold caucuses
or primaries his name won't appear on
ballots until Super Tuesday but he's a
billionaire and he's used millions
already to let you know who he is in
advertising some of the ads featuring
dogs and ice cream were admittedly a bit
offbeat recent polling data outside of
Iowa and New Hampshire has him
registering in Utah in Florida for
example recent polling of Democratic
voters has him in double digit territory
it is a different approach but will it
work especially if one candidate like
Bernie Sanders or Joe Biden wins a
majority of the early States and gains
momentum we have a national footprint
right now in over 35 states with about a
thousand people on the ground Tim
O'Brien is the Bloomberg campaigns
senior advisor
we're running three campaigns
simultaneously essentially we're running
a general election campaign right out of
the gates against Donald Trump we're
also running obviously a primary
campaign that really hinges on Super
Tuesday States as our first showing and
we're also prioritizing a handful of
battleground states where we think the
2020 election is going to be won or lost
I've been in six of those states so far
so I've been in Pennsylvania Michigan
Wisconsin Arizona North Carolina and I'm
in Texas now and I'll be going to
Florida next week and in those states
are the ones that are high priority for
us but we're we're competitive in all
the states but not Ohio nuts know we
have a big ground operation in Ohio
already but I think I think you know
Ohio is gonna be a tough state Ohio I
think is pretty red right now whereas I
think Arizona and Texas are very purple
and I think we can help push it into
blue let's talk about the early states
if Bernie Sanders
until like you know runaway train with
like three of the four early states
what's the strategy then for Super
Tuesday Minh how do you fight that
momentum runaway train is it's not a
good image for Bernie but he has
momentum you know I think there's a good
chance he's gonna win both Iowa New
Hampshire you know there's a chance that
that Joe Biden may not even be in the
top two in either of those states so I
think there's gonna have to be some
reconsideration of among voters of where
everything resides in a wake of these
first two contests certainly after the
first four and I think it'll you know I
think that'll sort of be rooted in where
the the middle of the party and the
moderate part of the party sees itself
and where the liberal wing of the party
sees itself and and what kinds of
rational alliances can be made so people
focus on the most important thing which
is beating Donald Trump there are plenty
of Californians who would support Mike
Bloomberg and I know because I've spoken
to some of them I know that's not a
really big surprise to hear that some
Californians would support mr. Bloomberg
but even some of them have expressed to
me some skepticism about his campaign
because he isn't competing in the first
four states and you know I've heard
people who are very supportive of mr.
Bloomberg question how serious the
candidacy is if he's you know not
debating and not campaigning the way
other candidates are you know I think if
they started to pay closer attention to
what we're doing I don't think any there
should be any doubts about how serious
he is about this campaign he sees it as
the culmination of his life's work the
money resources an organization that
he's putting into play here are going to
be at the foot of the Democratic Party
or whoever the ultimate Democratic
nominee is even if it's not Mike I think
if this was just someone on a sort of
breezy vanity run you wouldn't see those
kinds of things everything about his
policy positions aren't about an
affluent individual trying to buy the
election it's about somebody with a long
track record of public service
as an elected official as a
philanthropist and as an entrepreneur
wanting to bring all those skills to
bear in this race and I think the reason
he's going up in the polls is because
I'll recognize that you just said that
that he this is sort of the culmination
of his life's work that's a pretty big
statement we've heard mr. Bloomberg say
he's gonna run before why is this time
different I know he's always been a big
data guy what is it this time around is
the data showing something or is this
about the president I think it's both I
think I think he believes there's a
five-alarm fire in the White House and
that Donald Trump is a threat to a lot
of institutions and values that people
across the country hold close in ear and
that Trump is running roughshod over
those and if he gets reelected he would
be very unfettered and more damage would
be done so I think that's what's first
that's what's front of mind from Mike
Bloomberg right now I also think he did
look at the data he looked at a lot of
polling data and what he saw was that
the current field wouldn't beat Donald
Trump in a general election
that's not the polling data shows the
polling data when you put most the top
tiering polling data when he when he got
in and we were doing a lot of
state-by-state granular polling data
that we were commissioning our spells it
wasn't independent polls he sees this
race as a referendum around competence
and character and that Donald Trump is
sorely lacking in both those categories
Mike Bloomberg has those things in
abundance voters are recognizing that
he's someone who's a very pragmatic
progressive he cares about a lot of
issues the liberal wing of the party
holds close and values highly but he
knows how to make the math add up and
not to finance those kind of programs
with moonshots and one of the things
that the liberal wing of the party does
seem to have a problem with is this idea
of buying the election right senator
senators Warren and Sanders have both
made sort of accusatory comments of you
know this this idea of buying the
election you know blanketing the
airwaves with ads I mean heck you guys
are even spending millions on a Super
Bowl ad how do you sort of like fight
that narrative or is that precisely the
point is he basically saying you know
what I'm doing this my way I'm gonna
I've got a lot of money and I'm gonna
spend it well I mean we are doing it his
way but
he's not buying an election I think he's
buying exposure if you could buy an
election other candidates who've been
spending a lot of their own money on
this wouldn't be pulling in lower
numbers there's no question that that
the money he's put into play
gives him visibility with voters but if
you didn't have a very compelling track
record behind him all of the advertising
in the world wouldn't get traction with
voters the reality is is that there's no
one running on the Democratic side right
now who has the governing experience of
Mike Bloomberg one of the things that he
did as mayor though which she's already
addressed and apologized for was this
this you know the stop and frisk policy
it seems like a no-win here moving
forward on the one end you've got
questions about you know why that policy
was championed for as long as it was and
on the other hand you get people saying
why are you apologizing for it how do
you move forward with with questions
about stop and frisk well I think
questions about stop and frisk are
important I think they opened the door
to a rich conversation stop-and-frisk
was a mistake Mike stood by it for too
long I think you deep he's deeply pained
by the notion that it means that he's a
racist which he most profoundly isn't I
think his goal was to reduce gun
violence on streets but the program and
that approach was a mistake he's
apologized for it we will continue as a
campaign to apologize for it and I think
it's a measure of his self-confidence
and openness as a candidate that he can
apologize for his mistakes
having said that stop and frisk hardly
defines his tenure as mayor of New York
he lowered the incarceration rate by
over 34% there's no other big city where
it dropped that much so stop and frisk
was not about throwing people in jail
um you know he's choosing to focus on on
gun violence in his Superbowl ad and I'm
wondering why what went into making that
decision when you have arguably you know
if not the most watched event on
television it certainly is right up
there why bring that to the attention of
potential voters on Superbowl Sunday
because I think it contrasts very
sharply with where Donald Trump has been
on this issue we have had a wave of gun
violence
in the United States a sharp escalation
in hate crimes and domestic terrorism
that are directly the result of I think
the hateful language that Trump has
deployed when he ran as a candidate and
now as a president and an unwillingness
to do the right thing on stemming gun
violence and this is something that
touches families it most profoundly
touches communities of color some of the
most vulnerable communities in our
country but it's in our schools it's
where people pray and we can't say we're
a civilized country if our kids have to
hide under their desks or worry about
hiding under their desks because there's
an active shooter in a school I think
it's an issue that defines how much
purpose and commitment Mike Bloomberg
has is solving complex problems and how
much Donald Trump is 'simply and simply
avoided doing that what's his take on
health care that's a topic on the debate
stage that really seems to dominate
among the Democratic candidates what
role do insurance companies play you
know in a Bloomberg administration he
doesn't back Medicare for all he thinks
if people have private insurance they
should be entitled to keep it but he
also thinks that that the public option
needs to be made much more robust and
needs the full backing of the federal
government so every American regardless
of their income or means can get access
to high-quality health care he believes
that we are not a civilized society if
people can't get quality health care for
themselves or their children because
it's it's so wildly unaffordable and I
think we all know what the factors are
that make it unaffordable it's it's the
insurance companies the hospitals and
the pharmaceutical companies they have a
strong presence in the American health
care system there's a lack of
transparency around pricing there's a
lot of control around the delivery of
services both those things combine to
really escalate costs for the average
American and I think Mike would really
want to intervene in that nexus of
interests to make sure Americans are
well served when it comes to health care
finally one last question for you mr.
Bloomberg is older now and we have heard
him you know say he's gonna run before
this may be the last time that he would
run you know I do a lot of stuff with
Mike including you know preparing him
around policy issues and he has a ton of
energy and by the end of some of these
sessions I'm tired and he's not any
significantly older than I am
he has a bottomless amount of an energy
a very clear sense of purpose and a
great clarity of mind I think Mike
Bloomberg is going to be easel bit like
Energizer Bunny I don't expect this
regardless of how it goes to be his last
rodeo he has too much enthusiasm and
energy for that Tim O'Brien thank you
thank you for having me this is Jimmy
Fowler with your Fox News commentary
coming up in the business of news
Geraldo Rivera has covered a lot of
territory this place is in this school
it's a dark corner where we throw
children who aren't pretty to look at
it's the big town's leper colony from
the groundbreaking to the infamous now
what if anything this vault contains we
have no idea but we're going to find out
tonight he's been everything from a war
correspondent to a TV talk show host
currently a correspondent at-large for
Fox News someone just had the idea you
know it's it is not a you know a small
thing to last a half a century in the
public eye so he's looking back with a
new series on Fox nation
I am Geraldo 50 years in part one is
about the story that not only catapulted
his national career but also led to
change across America Willowbrook a
story that happened very early on in my
career is is obviously the the seminal
moment it's not Al Capone's vaults it's
not when I got my nose broken and the
brawl with the skinheads it's you know
not some of the more outrageous things
I've done were they serious reporting
I've done you know from one side of the
globe to the other it's the story of an
institution here in New York City called
Willowbrook it was at the time the
world's largest institution for the
developmentally disabled the population
we called mentally [ __ ] back in
those days now the r-word retardation is
not used it became a pejorative and it's
like the n-word they don't use it
anymore now people who have intellectual
disabilities or generally referred to as
having developmental disabilities so
that population the population once
described as [ __ ] were Wearhouse
back in that day I had no idea I had no
one in my family or close to me or my
friends families that as far as I knew
were developmentally disabled you know
occasionally you would see a kid with
Down syndrome on the street where it was
an obvious physical characteristic of
the that condition so you knew there was
something but it never sunk in
how did you it's not like they threw
open their doors and said to you come
and see how terrible this is but a
former staffer I think it was reached
out to you and then was able to sneak
you in to doctors who protested the
conditions and quit that day gave me a
key to one of the buildings building
number six I still have the key actually
the governor gave me the key 15 years
later when they finally closed all the
institutions in New York State they gave
me the key we went into one of the wards
Mike Wilkins one of the two doctors and
and me with my crew from Eyewitness News
we shot film in those days that's how
long ago it was we went in there and I I
tell you it was the worst thing I had
even imagined yeah I wasn't in obviously
World War two I didn't see the
concentration camps but the way what I
saw was comparable to the way
concentration camps were described to me
just deplorable conditions I read that
and it wasn't just children it was
adults too that had mental challenges
naked covered in feces I I know that
you've said you were worried or you
wondered if you were gonna be able to
put it on the air firstly because the
film was so terrible so graphic 60
people crowded in what would be like a
normal-size classroom I that they
couldn't feed themselves they couldn't
clean themselves they were there was no
remedial programs to teach them how to
do those things how to take care of
themselves the filth was overwhelming
overpowering the stench the the sounds
they were making
[Music]
we conjure them up in my nightmares that
they were fed kind of an assembly line
fashion they were shoveled oatmeal in
their mouths and they knew like birds
when the mom bird comes on with a worm
they knew to open their mouths and they
would the oatmeal was shoveled in one
scoop each and they they were dying of
pneumonia because the oatmeal would get
in their lungs and and they you know
they said they would they that was the
most common form of death the
respiratory illnesses it was this
nightmare that was so graphic and then
the lawyers were all over us you can't
put this on this is too shocking this is
what about the privacy rights we'll get
sued this than the other things so the
first night they obscured the faces of
the of the people in the institutions
but the the story was so it was so
dramatically received by New York at the
cynical big city this was a punch in the
gut to everybody it was such a tidal
wave of outrage that the next day the
second day we removed the obscuring of
the faces and said screw it you know if
we get sued we get sued then we had been
threatened
you know votes it for a sulli by state
officials they would sue us for trespass
for illegal entry and for the privacy
violations of the people inside they had
used this formula to deny access to
media their entire existence so we put
it on said you know we're gonna we're
gonna let the people see what this is
all about more money would certainly
help at least the kids would have closed
and they'd be cleaner than they are now
but it still basically be human
vegetables and a detention camp
no one ever sued us obviously in fact we
filed lawsuits and it was the lawsuits
filed by the New York Civil Liberties
Union and and others all joined into one
lawsuit that became the basis of the the
rulings of the court became the basis of
the Americans with Disabilities Act so
it affected everybody in the four
corners of the country and really spread
throughout the Western world the
institutional model
for caring for the developmentally
disabled was by that crusade rendered
obsolete and in instead you had for the
developmentally disabled the the
creation of this network of group homes
which is the situation now it is rare to
say the least for a journalist to affect
that sort of sweeping change in society
but your long career went to various
places after that you hosted your own TV
talk show for 11 I think it was 11 years
no small feat really charted your own
course did groundbreaking things along
the way however you did mention Al
Capone's vault still the subject of
parodies I think even today oh it's
become like a you know it's it's a catch
word in our back in 1986
few events on television had as much
hype as Geraldo's to our TV special this
is what you've come to say and this is
why we're here this massive concrete
chamber which some believe was built for
Al Capone some 30 million Americans
tuned in to watch a prime-time
excavation at a Chicago hotel famously
used as a residence by the gangster now
this actually wasn't Geraldo's idea he
was 42 had just been fired from ABC and
was sailing around the world when the
Tribune company called to pitch a
prohibition-era documentary and live TV
event would they find Al Capone's hidden
loot or maybe even a body he says he
felt like jumping off of the hotel where
he was staying but he got drunk instead
and the next morning with room service
he got a big surprise so he came in
pushing the cord and he said here these
of you I said what's this it was twenty
two job offers Wow
for every media company because the show
was such a sensation it was it was wild
it was the highest rated and remains the
highest-rated syndicated show ever so my
humiliation
was mitigated by the fact that now the
most famous unemployed person in America
had 22 job offers do you find it
hurtful after doing so many things and
so many wonderful things in your career
when people some people might only
remember you for the infamous things
when I think of the brawl with the
skinheads and Al Capone's vaults and
those kinds of things they pale in
comparison to the criticism I get for
being Donald Trump's friend I mean that
is really God you know a bridge too far
they they could take me being you know
burlesque but they can't take the fact
that I he's been my friend for 50 years
I'm gonna stay his friend I don't care
what you say you also don't always side
with the president you've criticized him
on a number of things most recently you
know for taking out Iran's top general
it was it was awful it was just awful I
disagree with the president of most
issues I have to type I disagree with
him on choice I disagree with him on
immigration reform I disagree with him
on gun control and I passionately
disagree with him his vision of the
Mideast in general when you disagree
with him on a subject if you tell him if
you stand up to him on something how
does he take it
because sometimes we read about this
vision of a man who you know basically
throws temper tantrums I mean is I don't
think that's that that's certainly not
my experience he jokes that I'm an 80
percenter that's the way he sees me you
know he loves me I think that he likes
me a lot I mean you know we were in
Seoul Celebrity Apprentice together his
last season you know I interviewed him
35 times for the daytime show you know I
been with him since the 70s you know he
and he I think that and in the same way
that I believe that he had a good
relationship with Bloomberg back in the
day yeah as New Yorkers there's a
special bond also that we share is there
anything left you'd like to do is there
some uncharted territory that you still
want to delve into I think that's an
excellent question I mean aside from
just doing hits on Hannity and Chuck
more than you know just going through
life being a pundit I'm very keen on
this series now this retrospective
because people forget or they weren't
born they weren't around the trajectory
of this career its thousands of
broadcasts thousands some of them
embarrassing
in retrospect many more though very
professionally done and some like the
Willowbrook story so special that I can
pointed them with pride and say see I
used this medium for positive social
change I did something I'm in my
probably 15th generation of television
critic now they were the ones they
excoriated me blasted me or ignored me
or embarrass me and they're gone and I'm
still here
miseries I'm still here it's not because
of you know just my drive or the fact
that I have hair at my late stage in
life it's because there's something that
resonates with enough people to keep me
on the air you do have great hair though
Geraldo Rivera listeners can stream
I am Geraldo 50 years part-1 Willowbrook
on Fox Nation and thank you very much
sir for spending so much time with us my
pleasure thank you
[Music]
America is a special place every four
years we do something most people across
the globe only dream of democracy 2020
it's in your hands
Fox News America is watching it's time
for your fox news commentary what's on
your mind
Super Bowl 54 is upon us congratulations
Super Bowl you made it to 54 years just
think and 25 more you'd be old enough to
run for president as a Democrat speaking
of such things as a Republican I got to
tell you this is a very tough Super Bowl
for me to pick because on the one end
you've got San Francisco and that's
Nancy Pelosi's team but on the other end
elizabeth warren claims she's related to
some of the chiefs so while i don't
really care about the team's i've paid
my rent for the past 15 years betting
football so I feel like I owe you guys
some serious gambling analysis and here
it is first and foremost my best bet is
the over 65 and a half buffalo wings
from me it's gonna get ugly in the fela
house right now I'm eating like I'm in
my third trimester at this point but my
second best bet is the 49ers to win the
game I think Nick Bosa and the Niners
defensive front can overwhelm the Chiefs
at the line of scrimmage and slow down
Patrick mahomes very similar to the way
the Broncos did it to the Panthers a few
years back and extremely similar to what
my New York Giants did to the Patriots
twice in the big game you remember those
they sack the pants off of Brady and he
was so upset he was seen rage eating a
cashew after the game cuz that's all
Gisele lets him have Michael Bloomberg
is eating ten million dollars with his
idiotic Super Bowl and he plans to run
during the game earth to Bloomberg
nobody wants to hear from the guy who
tried to ban soda and sugary foods while
they're eating so much they'll be out of
breath reading this is like hiring a guy
to sell beachfront getaways outside a
movie theater that just showed jaws but
whatever whoever wins the game
Niners Chiefs I don't care just please
by all means go to the White House don't
listen to all of these social media
dopes who pressure your not to go
because they don't like the president
nobody's inviting them this is like me
telling jay-z not the date Beyonce it's
not really an option for me so it's easy
to say listen man you
the Super Bowl he did something amazing
you earned a unique opportunity that
very few people get and not only is it a
unifying moment for the country but it's
a win for you because you get to go out
and witness all of that history you're
not only meeting this president you're
meeting every president and you get to
walk into the Oval Office and sit at the
same desk as a Lincoln and Monica
Lewinski Niners 21 Kansas City 20 sorry
cheese fans but look at it on the bright
side at least you're not a reporter who
has to cover a ticker tape parade on the
sidewalks of San Francisco watch where
you step guys and happy Superbowl
I'm Jimmy Fowler catch me every day on
Fox across America on Fox News Radio
[Music]
you have been listening to the FoxNews
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
the Fox News radios hourly newscast at
FoxNews podcasts calm and for
up-to-the-minute news visit Fox news.com
[Music]
subscribe and listen to the latest from
fox news podcasts it's the impeachment
which end with Fox News legal analyst
Greg Jarrett a must listen to get the
full legal view of their current
impeachment go to Fox News podcast